hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade and Mathias and
Jessi over there say hi guys be more
enthused se we're playing the seven
second challenge which was made by Dan
and Phil it's actually an app that we're
playing on her phone that you can get
today I'm not sponsored by but hey it's
it's their dam filler crew guys how tall
Danny fell yeah uh seven foot and eight
three yeah seven foot and a three they
are literally Giants they make the four
foot seven guy that I am feel so tiny in
comparison like I feel intimidated by
just being around OMG mark are you
really four foot seven yes I got my
phone right here to seven second
challenge basically you have seven
seconds to do whatever the app tells you
if you don't do it you failed it if you
do it you nailed it but do 5 squats and
make an eagle noise with each one go
holy me woah oh yeah they sure the chair
is gonna bring I just pull my [ __ ]
strippers okay good job he nailed it hey
put up a graphic this is nailed it say
the most random sentence you can come up
with go Ziggy zaggy Philly Polly's pigs
on a stick with lots of toys and all
that stuff boy was there a verb what
were the zig zaggy pigs doing okay I got
free fails I fail yeah there was no Ferb
down is random
invent a superhero with a useless power
and name them underpants man with the
power to melt cheese power yes ah power
what you're done putting wishes enough
underpants man is already a super here
you idiot yeah yes yeah Cat Man fans
who's that dude it's captain under isn't
that like the whole book series cat
Marvel you feel knowing what that is
wait for real here we go ready invent
flip then we were to do someone to do
five animal impressions and name them as
you go
ah giraffe Oh sheep goat blur bear
hoorah tiger rawr
okay goat was not what he failed god
damn it make the highest pitched noise
you can go higher describe a cloud
without using the words rain or sky go
fluffy white particles here Wow
that is it really good give me a give me
a nice cloud like nailed it what three
things would you do if you swap bodies
with the opposite sex boobs touch ha ha
ha ice cream dance on skates I wouldn't
touch give me an ax fail then oh no that
was a good nail failed it eat a huge
invisible plate of spaghetti and finish
it nailed it but at what cost make up
three lies about yourself I am the best
I'm not a photographer
and I too late you
that's uh I wasn't lying on the world I
am the word was it what I failed it yeah
that was correct
Wow gimme it failed it on a bratwurst
because he's the worst wage out of my
mouth Beckett an imaginary cat down from
a tree using only your feet and elbows
go okay it just looks like you're like
riding a bicycle all over everything
okay everybody everybody who has a cat
knows it does not come when you call
right I'm all right no cats don't
respond I'm gonna do them be riding a
bike up the truth dance like an angry
Swan Creek leak leak leak
you're gonna welded say five compliments
about yourself oh I'm so handsome my
muscles oho so huge I don't even work
out I got muscle I've got a really great
voice and look my hair is fantastic
feels like a calm down how did he get it
wrong cuz they were all lies it was all
true give a speech as if you were just
voted the president of pizza wait
president a penis they're going already
uh pig sighs delicious thank you I see
that one evil boy happy you Nicholas
three jobs you'd rather cry for hours
than do teaching YouTube and fail in a
boo oh give this video a like if you
failed it calculate how many seconds are
in seven minutes
it's 420 I think yeah that's right Wow
sing a song about bricks go Briggs or
the foundation of my world they are so
good and great nail thank you be a chair
for the person holding the phone what Oh
touch your toes then high-five me five
times go at once
you don't know how to count dude five
for those four to lay the mat and roll
the team bad boy
walk like an astronaut on the moon here
look back there no one can see what
you're doing and you're shaking your ass
in my face as unpleasant on all counts
Oh God boo get up
I do an impression of two antelope
escaping a cheetah Go Go who's the goat
yeah I like the giggling at the end of
your scream did you just get out of I
should say three things you wouldn't say
in front of your grandparents go um Wow
look at that booty uh Benny got back you
to Athens and you still fail uh uh uh uh
uh it's not say to you it's saying in
front of your grandpa my grandma that
was the seven second challenge we really
hope you enjoyed it if you did let us
know down in the comments below maybe
leave a like for these guys here thank
you all so much for joining us and
remember this Dan and Phil's app you can
find it on the App Store I think it's $2
when I got it so thank you again and
check out the thises channel for another
challenge we did it prior to this so
thanks again everybody and as always
we'll see you in the next video bye-bye